hey everyone welcome to the simply learn
channel and today we are having a quiz
on c plus
we would request you to bear with us as
we wait for few more minutes for people
to join the stream
also to take part in the quiz it is
highly recommended to use the mobile
phone and visit the website
www.menti.com and use the code that is
mentioned on the screen
you can use a different tab on the
browser to take part in the quiz as well
so if you want to be a successful c plus
plus programmer
which better way to test your knowledge
than to take a quiz
we will be proceeding with the quiz soon
let's wait for a few more people to join
before we begin
be sure to stick around till the end of
the quiz for a chance to win amazon
vouchers
if you are one of the top three winners
while we wait for others
if you'll be the winners of top three
you'll get the amazon vouchers worth
rupees
500 to 1000
while we wait for others to join let's
take a quick look at what c plus plus
programming language is why we use c
plus plus programming language features
of c plus plus language and applications
of c plus plus programming
to take part in the quiz it is highly
recommended to use your mobile phone to
visit the website
www.menti.com and use the code that is
mentioned
the code is available on the screen you
can also use a different tab on your
browser to take part in the quiz but our
live stream will be broadcasting the
results as soon as the answers are given
by the participants
so it's beneficial to have both the
screens visible at the same time
once you open the link and input the
code just wait for the quiz to start and
be ready to answer the questions
the quicker you answer the more points
you'll get so be sure to think fast and
click faster
so now we are going to wait for few more
minutes to let other people join before
starting a quiz today
meanwhile let's understand what c plus
plus is
c plus plus is a general purpose
cross-platform intermediate level
programming language that was created as
a more advanced version of the c
computer language
c plus plus was developed by john
strawstrom in 1979
when john started his work on c with
glasses that is the previous name of c
plus plus by the way it was designed to
be a superset of the c programming
language his goal was to incorporate
object-oriented programming features
into the c programming language
virtual functions operator overloading
constants single line comments and other
features were added in
1982 the language name is also changed
from c with classes to c plus
c is an intermediate level programming
language it is describes as an
intermediate level language because it
has both high level and low level
features
the c plus plus language had four major
updates in 2011 2014 2017 and 2020.
in c plus 11 there were plenty of new
features expanding the standard library
and giving c plus plus programmers more
option
c plus plus 14 was released in 2014 with
minor updates to c plus
in c plus 17 various features were added
variable declaration
if and switch nested namespaces fold
expression etc
now let's understand why we use c plus
language
so c plus plus is an object oriented
programming language that offers
programs a clear structure and promotes
code reuse which reduces development
costs
c plus is portable programming language
that may be used to create applications
that run on variety of systems
you can learn to program in c plus from
the roots up
you have to explain what you do in which
helps you gain a better understanding of
c plus plus language
c plus will teach you a variety of
concepts such as dynamic libraries
efficient memory management pointers and
much more
now
coming to features of c plus
there are various features of c plus
plus so let's have a look at them first
is rich library
c plus plus provides users with a large
number of built-in libraries that aid in
the development of software in a more
efficient and effective manner
such libraries can be accessed by anyone
simply using the right header files
second is memory management it is
basically allocating memory space to
application in order to improve
performance
c plus plus has dynamic memory
allocation which allows you to free and
allocate memory at any time
c plus is fast and powerful language
in terms of speed it outperforms all
other programming languages
c plus plus is powerful programming
language that supports variety of
approaches including procedural
programming object oriented programming
functional programming etc
it also has a large number of data types
functions and operators
operating systems browsers games and
other application can also be created as
a result
c plus plus is platform independent
so c plus plus is platform dependent
its programs are machine independent
which means they can run on a variety of
machines with little or no changes but
it is not platform independent
therefore programs can only be run on
the platform on which they were written
and compiled
c plus plus is an object-oriented
programming language which means it has
both object oriented properties that
enable easier maintenance and
development
inheritance encapsulation abstraction
polymorphism are the concepts of object
oriented programming
now moving on to applications of c plus
first is graphics
c plus plus is a high performance and
fast programming language that is ideal
for 3d animation
my image processing and modeling as well
so c plus plus is used for operating
system as well
all operating systems including
microsoft windows macintosh linux are
written in c plus
because it is strictly type and fast
programming language that is why it is
preferred
c plus plus is also used to create
databases and database management
systems such as mysql redis and oracle
many top
it organization including google and
wikipedia rely on these softwares
c plus plus is used to create embedded
system
c plus plus is the principal programming
language used in a variety of embedded
devices including medical machines smart
watches and many more
it is also used to create compilers
c plus are used as backend programming
languages because c plus plus is a low
level language it is more closely
related to the hardware as a result it
is used as a backend component in the
compilation system of newer and modern
programming languages
c plus is used for browsers
to ensure that users do not have to wait
for the content to appear on the screen
rendering engines must execute faster
and since c plus plus has a faster
execution time it aids in development of
browser rendering engines
all the major browsers including google
chrome mozzarella and others were
supported by c plus
all right
so let's start with the c plus plus quiz
now
also to take part in the quiz it is
highly recommended
to use your mobile phone to visit the
website
the website is mentioned like
www.menti.com
and use the code that is mentioned
the code is available on the screen as
well as we can see you can also use a
different tab on your browser to take
part in the quiz but our live stream
will be broadcasting the results as soon
as the answers are given by the
participants
so it's beneficial to have both the
screens visible at the same time
once you open the link and input the
code
just wait for the quiz to start and be
ready to answer the questions
the quicker you answer the more points
you'll get so be sure to think fast and
click faster then only you'll get to the
top of the leaderboard
again guys
www.menti.com you have to visit there
and put the code over there which is
mentioned on the screen
all right then let's start with our
first question
which one of the following is not a
member of the class
a virtual function b static function c
friend function or d constant function
make sure to click faster and think
faster as well
we have like
12 second left
virtual function static function friend
function or constant function
time is up
now let's see
14 people manage to give the right
answer so friend function yeah
c friend function is the correct option
the friend function is not a class
member a friend function is just a
function that is declared outside of a
class but can access the class private
and protected members they have the same
access permissions as the class member
but they aren't true class members
whereas virtual function static function
and constant function are the class
members
now let's have a look at the
leaderboards and mole
and mole is at the top position
prachi is at the second position dr
centipede is at third position and
hershey is at fourth position
all right guys
so now we can go ahead to the second
question
time's up guys
so let's have a look at the
correct option
so as we can see
both a and b is the correct option
so yeah
write function and read function both a
and b that is is the correct option
because read function is used to access
the file and write function is used to
modify or edit the data of the file so
that is why option d is the correct
option
now let's have a look at the
leaderboards
so as we can see
and mole was at the first position now
harshit is at the first position
all right patch is at the second
position and
doctor centipede is again at the third
position
very well guys
now
let's move on to the third question
so how can we restrict the dynamic
allocation of objects of a class using
new
options are by making an empty private
new and new operators
be by making an empty private new
operator c by overloading new operator
or d by overloading new operator or new
operators
make sure to answer faster
then only you'll get elevated to the
first position of the leaderboard
i think everyone has voted and
by making an empty private new a new
operator that is option a and majority
of the people have managed to give the
right answer that is
11 people have give the right answer so
yeah option a
by making an empty private new new
operator
the new and delete operator in c plus
permit dynamic allocation and delocation
of objects the heap is a pool of memory
that these operator use to allocate
memory of 4 objects the special function
operator new is called by the new
operator
whereas the special function operator
delete is called by the delete operator
so if we will declare the empty private
new and the new operator then the
objects cannot be created or we can say
restricted within the class as well as
outside the class
so
very well
now let's have a look at the leaderboard
now cushy as that
third position i think
again cushy is at third position harshit
is at second position and pachi
has given the fastest sensor
all right very well guys
moving on to the question number four
which of the following is true about
this pointer
a it is passed as a hidden argument to
all function calls b it is passed as a
hidden argument to all static functions
see it is passed as a hidden argument to
all the non-static function calls or d
none of the above
we have to select
which is true about this pointer
keep in mind guys
you'll have to think as well
as well as pick the correct option
so everyone has voted and eight people
has managed to give the right answer
that is option c
so all non-static member function calls
receive the this pointer as a hidden
parameter and it is available as local
variable within the body of all
non-static functions the memory address
of the current object is held by this
pointer which is a constant pointer
this reference is not available because
static member function can be called
without specifying an object
so yeah guys this is the correct option
now let's look at the leaderboard
again give the fastest answer she's at
position one kushi is at position two
and and mole at position three
hershey has shifted to position down now
all right
now moving on to the fifth question
so operator overloading is done with the
help of a special function called dash
which describes the special task of an
operator you have to select
what comes inside that dash
a operator function b overloading
function c detail function or d special
task function be quick guys
if you want to join the quiz guys
www.menti.com you can visit there and
put the code which is mentioned
and i think the time is almost over
so time's up
now let's see
operator function 13 people manage to
give the right answer very well
all right now prachi is again at
position one and more at position two
centipede has
or cushy has maintained
his or her position so very well guys
harshitas is at position seventh or
eighth
set is at position fifth
very well guys you can also elevate to
the first row second or third position
all right
now question number six
what is the correct syntax for including
a user defined header file in c plus
as you can see options hash include my
file dot h
so there are minor changes with the
syntax as we can see so you have to
select the correct
way of writing the header file in c plus
it's bit
complex but yeah 13 8 people managed to
give the right answer
all right so eight people managed to
give the right answer that is hash
include my file with double quotes
so yeah guys c is the correct option
to include a user defined header file in
c plus quotation marks are used that is
dot extensions are used for user defined
header files
to include a user defined header file
one should use hash include name dot h
that is enclosed within the double
quotes
so now let's have a look at the
leaderboard again
all right i think this time harshit has
managed to give the fastest answer and
but prachi is still at position one
and
array has managed to give has managed to
secure position number two
congratulations sarah
all right now
let's move on to the
next question
that is question number seven
be quick guys then only you can elevate
to the first position so select the
wrong option you have to select the
wrong option over here
options are a void is used when the
function does not return a value
b void is also used when the value of a
pointer is null see void is used as a
base type for pointers to objects of
unknown type or d void is a special type
we have to select the wrong option over
here
keep in mind guys
we have five second left
times up all right
now 10 people managed to give the right
answer that is option b
all right guys so yeah option b that is
void is also used when the value of a
pointer is null is the graph correct
option
and the rest of the option is true in
terms of void
all right now let's see
i think this time sid is fastest
all right cushy
is now at position two very well
prachi again is at position one she's in
good touch today okay
all right
now question number eight
all right which of the following
statements is not true about
pre-processor directives option a they
begin with a hash symbol option b they
do not produce code by themselves c they
end with a semicolon d
these must be written on a single line
which of the following statement is not
true keep in mind guys not true that is
false about preprocessor directives we
have to select that statement
so here we go
time's up and 15 people manage to give
the right answer very well guys
so yeah that is option c is correct the
pre-processor directive
don't use semicolons this is because
they use a line break to delimit
statements
this means that you cannot have multiple
directives per line
right
now let's have a look
right
yeah
very well practice at position one kush
is at position two
array is at position three
now we have to
move on to the next question guys that
is question number nine
be quick guys
so what will happen when a structure is
declared
all right option a it will allocate the
memory b it won't allocate any memory c
it is declared and initialized d none of
the above
we have enough time for that
let's see who will answer fastest
guys if you want to join the quiz
www.mente.com you have to visit there
and put the code which is mentioned
all right guys time's up
let's see
seven people give the right answer that
is it won't allocate any memory
that is right
so the structure will not be initialized
as long as it is declared as a result no
ram will be allocated memory is
allocated only when a structure instance
is created until no memory is required
so let's have a look at the leaderboard
again
right
wow array is now now at position one
very well array and sid is at position
two prachi has shifted to position three
hershey is at position four kush is at
position five
all right guys
there is a major shifting over here
very well guys now
let's move to the next question
question number 10
so what happens to a function defined in
a class without any complex operation
like loop etc
so option a it becomes a virtual
function of a class b this becomes a
default function of a class c this
becomes an inline function of a class d
the program displays an error
make sure to select the correct option
as fast as you can
what happens to a function defined in
class without any complex operation
this is the question
and everyone has voted wow all right so
15 people managed to give the right
answer which which is the majority
and
let's see
very well
array is at again at position once it is
at position two
and practice at position three
all right and mole has managed to give
the fastest answer very well and more
now a quick reminder guys top three
scorers can send your screenshots after
the quiz ends
so whosoever will come to the first
three positions
will be sending the screenshots to
youtube contest
simplylearn.net
and then you will receive your amazon
voucher
so you can either click a picture or you
can
make a screenshot of that then you'll
have to mail at youtube
contest at simplyone.net only the top
three scorers guys
in the end whosoever becomes the top
three scorers they'll have to send the
screenshot at this mail
all right guys so i hope you understand
how to do that now
let's move on
to question number 11
all right so pick the right statement
about string objects in c plus plus
all right a string object must be
terminated by a null character b string
objects have a static size c string
objects use more memory than necessary d
string objects have a dynamic size
alright guys
come on let's pick up the right answer
now
let's do a major shuffling over here
in the next leaderboard
we have to pick the right statement and
here we go
nine people manage which is the majority
very well guys
okay so yeah
d option that is
string objects have a dynamic size is
the correct option
so because string objects are dynamic in
nature their size vary depending on the
value
so they do not exceed the required size
and the null character
is not required at the conclusion
all right guys
now
let's see the leaderboard
so arrays at position once it is at
position two there is no major shifting
now
all of
the folks have maintained their position
very well
question number 12.
all right guys try to answer faster
which function is used to get the length
of a string in c plus plus
a
str.length b str.size
c the two functions size and length d s
t r dot max size
this is a pretty easy question i believe
and
i hope that most of the forks tried to
manage the
correct option
so times up yeah
so here we go
so six people managed to give the
correct option majority of them
gave the option a which is not correct
so the correct option is c that is the
two functions size and length so yes
guys size and length are used to get the
size of a string in c plus plus you can
use both to get the length of the string
it is entirely up to you whether to use
length function or the size function
let's see
is at position three now
she has shifted to position four
array again has maintained the first
position sit is at position two
[Music]
all right guys
next is 13th question
so operator overloading is
a making new c plus plus operators be
giving new meaning to existing c plus
plus operators c giving c plus plus
operators more than they can handle d
making c plus plus operators work with
objects
make sure to answer quickly
then only you can elevate to positions
one two and three
top scorers will get the amazon voucher
guys so
make sure to
pick the correct option
time's up let's see
16 people manage to give the right
answer giving a new meaning to existing
c plus plus operator that is
option b
so yeah giving new meaning to existing c
plus operators we can change the
behavior of operators for user defined
types like objects and structures in c
plus this is known as operator
overloading
an
overloaded declaration is one that has
the same name as previously declared
declaration in the same scope but with
different arguments and clearly diff
with different arguments clearly
different definitions
so option b is the correct option
now let's see
she has managed to give the fastest
answer
and her she's at position three sid is
at position two arrays again at position
one very well guys
akshay swooped is at position seventh i
guess
and all right
question number 14 guys
if you want to override the constructor
default values for an object you are
initiating you must
also overwrite
a all parameters to the left of the
value all parameters to the right of the
value c all other parameters to that
constructor d
no other parameters to that constructor
come on guys
try to manage to give the correct option
now
five second left i believe
and here we go
time's up
all right
so option a majority have given the
right answer very well guys so yeah
option a that is all parameters to the
left of the value so in this case in
order to override default values of a
constructor we must override all
parameters to the left of the value
so yeah guys option a is correct
let's have a look at the leaderboard now
i believe there will be a major
shuffling now
let's see
mole has given the fastest answer array
is at position one set is at position
two hershey is at position three kushi
is at position four patch is
at position five
okay guys now
let's move on to the next question that
is question number 15
so
be quick guys which of the following
statement is valid
we can create new c plus plus operators
b we can change the precedence of the c
plus plus operator see we can change the
associativity of the c plus operator d
we cannot change operator templates so
we have to select
the valid statement which is right
the other three options would be wrong
or we can say not valid we have to
select the valid statement out of these
options
one guys we can do this
right time's up guys
so now we can see
very well guys
most of the folks manage to give the
right answer that is d
we cannot change the operator templates
is the only valid statement the rest of
the statements are not valid all right
let's have a look at leaderboards now
as you can see kushi managed to give the
fastest answer now
all right very well cushy now
let's move on to the next question again
question number 16 be quick guys try to
answer as soon as you can
and pick the correct option
so if inner catch handler is not able to
handle exception then a program
terminates abnormally b compiler will
look for outer try handler c compiler
will check for appropriate catch handler
out outer try block d none of the above
we'll have to select the correct option
you have to fill the gap in the end
so yeah guys
let's do this
time's up and let's have a look
option c
compiler will check for appropriate
catch handler of outer try block it is
the correct option if inner catch
handler is not able to handle exception
then compiler will check for appropriate
cache center of outer try block
all right
very well
now let's have a look at leaderboard
again
again khushi is
has given the fastest answer
and the positions are maintained i
believe
okay
question number 17
so in nested try block if inner catch
handler gets executed then
dash will have to fill the dash
okay a outer catch handle will also get
executed program execution stops
immediately compiler will jump to outer
cache handler and then execute remaining
executable statements of main
d compiler will execute remaining
executable statements of outer try block
and then the main function
so it's bit complex you'll have to read
the complete options
so yeah guys
try to do that
let's see
how many will able to give the right
option select the right option
very well
it was not expected but yeah very well
guys 14 people managed to give the right
answer that is option d
so in
nested try block if inner cache handler
like if inner cache enabler gets
executed then the compiler will execute
remaining executable statements of outer
try block and then the main function
so very well guys
now let's have a look at the leaderboard
most of the people have managed to give
the right answer
she who she has given the right answer
correct the fastest answer i would say
and has shifted to position three
very well hershey shifted to position
four
all right question number 18
so yeah
in nested try blocks if both inner and
outer cache handlers are not able to
handle the exception then dash
so option a compiler executes only
executable statements of main b compiler
issues compile time errors about it
c program will be terminated abnormally
d program will be executed without any
interruption
in nested try block if both inner and
outer catches catch handler are not able
to handle exception then
keep in mind guys
all right time's up guys
let's have a look option c
very well guys majority has given the
right answer so if no inner outer catch
handler is available to handle the
exception then as usual the program will
show abnormal behavior
let's have a look at the leaderboards
now
rival said
[ __ ] harshit has given the fastest
answer wow all right shifted kushi to
the fourth position and managed to
reclaim the third position very well
array is at position one again as usual
and set is at position two
prachi is at position now sixth or
seventh
and all right guys let's move on to the
next question that is question number
19.
so in case of inheritance where both
base and derived class are having
constructor when an object of derived
class is created then
options are on the screen a constructor
of derived class will be invoked first
constructor of base class will be
invoked first converter constructor of
base class will be executed first and
followed by derived class d constructor
of derived class will be executed first
followed by the base class
so it will be a lengthy question i would
say
all right let's see
we'll give the correct option
select the correct option
all right
so
nine people manage to give the correct
option very well guys
so yeah option c
that is constructor of base class will
be executed first followed by derived
class
so when you derive something from a base
class you are actually deriving all of
the base class members but none of them
exist until a memory region is assigned
to them
because the base members are a part of
the base class they can only be stored
in memory by the base class constructor
as a result when you deduce them they
should already exist
as a result the constructor of the base
class will be executed first followed by
the derived class
all right guys
let's see what the leaderboard says
akshay
very well akshay
right array again managed to give the
fastest answer very well
r is at position one again
question number 20 guys
so when a child class inherits trades
from more than one parent class this
type of inheritance is called dash
inheritance it is pretty easy question
and i hope everyone
would select the right option
let's hope everyone managed to
select the correct option
when a child class inherits
from more than one parent class more
than one parent class this type of
inheritance is called multiple
inheritance yeah guys option a is the
correct option so multiple inheritance
occurs when a class inherits from more
than one
base classes
so the class can inherit features from
multiple base classes using multiple
inheritance
this is an important feature of object
oriented programming language such as c
plus plus
all right
let's see the leaderboard now
wow very well guys
uh
let's see
and more managed to give the fastest
answer very well in mole
and
there is no shifting i would say of the
position
all right
21 question
all right
let's see
so 21st question is what is the
difference between protected and private
access specifier in inheritance option a
private member is not inheritable and
not accessible in derived class b
protected member is inheritable and also
accessible in derived class option c
both are inheritable but private and
accessible in the derived class d both
are inheritable but protected is not
accessible in the derived class
again a lengthy question
let's see how many people will give the
correct option
everyone has voted and managed to give
the right answer like eight people
manage to give the right answer which is
option b
so protected member is inheritable and
also accessible in derived class
it is the difference between protect and
private access specific inheritance in c
plus plus there are three access
specifier as we know that public whose
members can be
accessed from anywhere
and then private whose members cannot be
accessed or viewed from outside of the
class then there is protected whose
members cannot be accessed from outside
of the class however they can be
accessed in inherited class only
so yeah guys option b is the correct
option
so now let's have a look at the
leaderboard again
array is the fastest desired position
too hershey's at position three kush is
at position four very well
okay
now let's move on to the next
question let's hope now the shuffling of
position will take place now
i hope so
all right
so class x class y and class z are
derived from class base this is dash
inheritance it is a pretty easy question
so i hope most of the forks would be
able to give the correct option
let's hope a multiple b multi-level c
hierarchical d single inheritance
it is pretty easy question i would say
and
we have enough time to answer this
make sure to answer as quickly as you
can because then only you can shift to
the first position guys
so everyone has voted and 10 people
managed to give the right answer very
well guys so yeah c hierarchical
inheritance
so basically a type of inheritance is in
which more than one class is inherited
from a single parent or base class
so this type of inheritance is called
hierarchical inheritance especially
those features which are common in the
parent class is also common with the
base class
so in this question option c is
is the correct hierarchical inheritance
is the correct option
all right guys
now let's
have a look at the leaderboard
sid
hershey
has managed to give the fastest answer
very well kushi
there is no major shuffling now as we
can see
no problem let's move on to the next
question
question number 23
be quick guys
which of the following is used to
release the dynamically allocated memory
in cpp or c plus
remove b delete c free d both b and c
so which of the following operator is
used to release the dynamical
dynamically allocated memory of c plus
very well guys everyone has voted before
the time
10 people have voted for delete six
people for free
so yeah i can see the confusion over
here but yeah
option b that is delete is the correct
option delete is used to release the
dynamically allocated memory in c plus
plus a delete operator is used to
de-allocate the memory space that is
dynamically created during the run time
on a c plus program using the new
operator
callocan malloc functions and so on like
that in other words the delete operator
is used to remove array and non-array
pointer objects from heap
so yeah guys uh second option that is
delete is the correct option
let's have a look at the leaderboard now
so kushi
has given the fastest answer as we can
see harshita has position three cities
at position two and arrays at position
one
very well guys
now let's move on to the next question
that is question number 24 this is the
second last question be
quick as
you can so that you can acquire the
first third positions first three
positions whosoever will get the first
three positions
will get amazon vouchers from us
so
let's have a look at question number 24.
dash is the feature of oop and mechanism
that binds together code and data it
manipulates and keeps both safe from
outside old it is very easy question
it is a question from moops concept
so yeah guys i hope you would be able to
give the correct
answer so a data binding b data
encapsulation c data abstraction d data
sorting
let's
hope the answers
most of the answers are right let's hope
that
now
time is up guys let's have a look
all right 12 people have selected data
encapsulation
and
five people have selected the correct
option which is data abstraction yeah i
can understand so that in
data encapsulation we
basically binds together code and data
together and that abstraction we
basically hide the
hide those parts which are not relevant
for the users and show which is relevant
for them
so abstraction is a feature of hoop and
mechanism that binds together code and
it manipulates and keep both both of
them safe from outside world
all right
now let's have a look at the leaderboard
array has given the
fastest answer
set is our position to hershey that
position three kush is at position four
very well guys
so there is no shuffling again all right
now coming to the last question that is
25th question
all right guys i hope everyone will
select the correct option because it is
the last question i would say and
it is easy which among these is more
effective while calling the c functions
a call by object b call by reference c
call by pointer or d call by value again
which among these is more effective
while calling the c plus functions
so you have to pick the correct option
now
a call by object b call by reference c
call by pointer or d call by reference
so everyone has voted very well guys ten
people manage to give the right answer
two people have selected call by object
four people have selected call by
pointer all right so yeah b option that
is call by reference so instead of
duplicating the value to new memories
the call by reference just
sends the reference of the memory
address of the passed values with seams
which saves time and memory
so yeah option b is the right option
and whosoever has selected
congratulation guys
now let's have a look at the leaderboard
let's see who are our top three scorers
who have managed to gain the position of
top three harshit has given the fastest
answer
so array array has selected is the
has acquired the first position i would
say and congratulations array
very well and sid is at position 2 and
harshit is at position 3
so congratulations guys
and
with that we have come to the end of
this quiz
so as we can see as you all can see top
three scorers can send your screenshots
to youtube contest
simplylearn.net
so you have to send the screenshot to
this mail
to receive your amazon vouchers
so keep in mind guys then only you can
get the amazon vouchers if you will mail
your screenshot to this site this mail
so with that we have come to the end of
this quiz guys
thank you for spending your valuable
time with us
thanks for watching stay safe and keep
learning